[Music]
as we tape this show polls are still
open officials won't declare a winner
for another eight hours
i think it's pretty clear though how
it's going to turn out so let me take a
moment to congratulate
my guy
congratulations president obama
you fought hard to win this election i'm
proud to say i fought right alongside
you from the early days of the campaign
into the last hours i supported you
doing what i could to inspire others the
way you inspired me
congratulations
on your second term
uh conan it is way too early to call it
for obama i mean the polls are still
open in half the country he could still
lose
i know andy
congratulations
president romney
you fought hard to win this election and
like you mr romney i know what it's like
to run my own business i need to stay
competitive and fiscally responsible and
so does my government and from the
beginning of your campaign 17 months ago
i've supported your quest for the
presidency every step of the way
congratulations president-elect romney
so well i guess you got your bases
covered there
not quite yet
holy crap herman cain
your secret plan worked just like i knew
it would congratulations to you and vice
president vin diesel
[Applause]